[Applaudissements]
depuis dimanche des milliers de
manifestants font face aux forces de
l'ordre
cette nuit encore les sentiments sont
mitigés après la victoire d'alexandre
loukachenko et sa reconduction au poste
de président pour un sixième mandat des
biélorusses plutôt ironique
regardez ce sont les cadeaux de
loukachenko
voici ce qui arrive nous sommes
reconnaissants envers notre président
nous sommes libres de marché de faire du
vélo de faire la queue la liberté est
partout des images fortes
la police faisant usage de matraques de
grenades à explosion et de gaz
lacrymogènes
le ministère de l'intérieur le confirme
une personne a trouvé la mort une
dizaine d'autres ont été blessées
dimanche au moins 3000 personnes ont été
arrêtées 39 policiers blessés
hospitalisés
plusieurs journalistes ont été arrêtés
au cours de ces élections notamment
russes mais ont été libérés selon
l'ambassade russe à minsk
alex honnold cash enhco dénonce des
manifestations manipulé depuis
l'étranger il voulait mettre le feu dans
le centre de minsk pour qu'après ils
puissent disperser les choses brûlé dans
tout minsk bien sûr ils n'y sont pas
parvenus
ils essaient de créer du désordre chez
nous j'ai prévenu qu'il n'y aurait pas
de révolution de maiden comme en ukraine
même si certains le souhaitent
les gens ont besoin de se calmer
l'opposant svetlana chicanos callas se
montre plus virulente et dénonce des
fraudes massives
la candidate a informé via sa porte
parole qu'elle ne participerait pas au
futur manifestation pour éviter des
provocations une élection qu'elle ne
considère pas comme légitime aujourd'hui
le pouvoir doit réfléchir à comment nous
céder le pouvoir
jusqu'à présent ils n'ont répondu que
par la violence à l'encontre de citoyens
biélorusses pacifique un caractère
démocratique du vote remis également en
cause par berlin qui a évoqué l'idée
d'une reprise des sanctions européennes
contre la biélorussie quant à la
présidente de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen
elle a demandé aux autorités locales un
nouveau décompte des voix